hey youtubers is Charlie so they finally
showed the first teaser trailer for
Doctor Who series 8 so I wanted to do a
full breakdown of everything we know
about all the episodes there's also a
really good chance that we could see the
first episode as early as Comic Con
which is at the end of the July or will
at least get the first full trailer if
you're finding me for the first time I'm
just doing bonus videos for Doctor Who
until it comes back be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'm also going to be doing weekly
episode reviews when it does start
airing along with q and A's and bonus
videos in a special giveaway so it'll be
just like the stuff I do for Game of
Thrones if you do a little reverse math
looking at the first trailer for the
50th anniversary they showed it about a
month before the actual episode so if
they only show us a trailer say a
comic-con that means that series 8
probably one premiere to the end of
August but I'll be posting updates
throughout the summer if you're confused
as to why they just said it's gonna
start in August and they didn't give us
a real day it's just because they're not
ready to announce it yet just because
they're still editing episodes like
they're literally not done with all the
episodes yet there's this weird thing in
TV where they can only start airing
episodes once they have enough to air
one each week until the end of the
season usually there's a break somewhere
in the middle but until they have say
like the first four or five episodes
completely done they can't air that
first episode that doesn't even take
into account the Christmas special they
haven't made a formal announcement yet
but there are 13 episodes and 12
typically end up being regular episodes
with one bonus Christmas special so
hopefully they won't wait til Comic Con
to make the announcement as to whether
or not they're actually doing a
Christmas special but I'll be posting
updates so don't worry so the good news
is that thanks to people camping out
outside the production whenever they
film outside we actually know quite a
bit about the first nine episodes not
plots necessarily just because that
would be a little bit spoilery episode 1
will be Victorian London with the
Paternoster gang it's basically the
story that's going to showcase what this
new regeneration is gonna be it'll spell
out his new personality and inform what
his new relationship with Clara is going
to be and set up the big overarching
plot remember whenever Matt Smith
debuted in the series 5 premiere they
set up the cracks in the universe and
that was a plot that ran all series and
they actually paid it off you know
whenever he were generated during the
Christmas special there will be a short
cameo from Matt Smith it's only supposed
to be audio from a phone call that he
placed before his regeneration that's
what all the business with handles in
the phone during that Christmas special
was all about episode
- is also from ben wheatley he's doing
both the first two episodes the only
teasers we've got are that it's a Dalek
story and the doctor will be going
quote-unquote behind enemy lines he did
tease the word lasagna and his Daleks do
not eat lasagna I have absolutely no
idea what that means but it's possible
that the doctor could be going back to
Skaro or he could be visiting a planet
in the middle of a Dalek battle some
other planet if you remember the doctor
actually traveled to Skaro in the series
7 premiere it was just a trick
but scar wasn't destroyed in the time
war it was just devastated before the
end of the time war I don't think the
events of the 50th anniversary changed
that though so it's probably still in
ruins episode 3 is Mark Gatiss episode
and the rumour title is robots of
Sherwood Tom Reilly is playing Robin
Hood Ben Miller is playing the Sheriff
of Nottingham and Trevor Cooper is
playing Friar Tuck it's actually the
Knights that are the robots Jenna Louise
Coleman even gets to shoot a bow Lord of
the Ring style for episode 4 the rumor
title is listen and it's actually Samuel
Anderson's first episode the premise
that they tease was when you talk to
yourself what if the person you are
talking to isn't really you and that
actually just reminds me of nightmare in
silver whenever mr. clever was trying to
take over the doctor's brain and the
doctor was talking to himself but
technically he was talking to mr. clever
who was also inside his mind there is
another character named reg that's
listed on the credits sheet and the only
other reg that I know of in the Doctor
Who universe was the character from the
2012 Christmas special that was married
to Madge but he was a much younger
character and I was in the past so it's
possible that this is either an older
version of that character or someone
totally different for episode 5 the
rumor title is time heist and it's
Keeley Hawes first episode as Miss
delphox she supposedly works at a bank
in the far future which would explain
the time heist theme but she's also
supposed to have a really dark secret
that's just the description I know a lot
of people are theorizing that she might
be the Rani or even a female master the
funny thing about that is is that I've
heard rumors about every single
character in series 8 with the exception
of Jenna Louise Coleman being the master
in disguise so I do not take that
seriously at all so we don't know what
the title is for episode 6 but it's
supposed to take place at coal Hill
School with the doctor posing as the
caretaker we
did get to see a little bit of the
inside of the school whenever Clara was
finishing a lesson during the 50th
anniversary special though the rumored
title of episode 7 is kill the moon and
we have seen pictures of Danny pink in a
spacesuit outside the TARDIS so I think
we can kind of connect that with this
episode I don't want to say that the
plot is based on blowing up the moon but
a title like kill the moon implies that
something's gonna get destroyed it also
kind of makes me think of the doctor's
wife and father being a living organism
inhabiting an asteroid so maybe there's
going to be something living inside the
moon that the doctor will have to save
so episode 8 the rumour title is mummy
on the Orient Express that's all we know
about it and the rumour title of episode
9 is flatlined we don't know anything
about episodes 10 through 13 we do get
the best info whenever people shoot
outdoor scenes just because people are
able to take pictures we don't know who
the writers are directors are of those
last four episodes but Neil Gaiman is
going to try and write another episode
depending on his schedule working out
and Peter Jackson said that talk of him
directing an episode is getting really
serious he joked about directing an
episode last year but because production
on The Hobbit was so intense no one
really took it very seriously
even Moffat hasn't officially announced
what they're gonna be doing at Comic Con
but there's usually a tumblr Meetup and
they're pretty good about bringing
footage so planned for either the first
full trailer or the first episode if
they show a big trailer next month I'd
say the odds of them showing that whole
episode are pretty good the BBC is
pretty good about teasing footage out
but for instance this first teaser
footage was really more of an image it
wasn't really a trailer now that we're
getting closer to the premiere I'm gonna
start doing more bonus videos so be sure
to subscribe to get everything
also let me know if you guys want me to
do a Q&A and feel free to leave me
suggestions for all those bonus videos
there's still a whole lot of time before
that first episode premieres my schedule
is a little bit crazy right now just
because I'm at a tentative wedding and I
am already behind on my Game of Thrones
video but I'll try and get everything
out as quick as possible right now click
here to learn more about the new
characters in series 8 and click here to
learn about the top 10 monsters I think
they should bring back thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you